so let's give it up for max and
grammerly hi everyone I'm max animal
co-founder of grammarly and today I'm
going to talk about bootstrapping and
I'm going to use grammarly a lot as an
example today so let me just say a few
words about the company to those who are
not familiar with it
grammerly is providing a high-powered
products that help people improve their
communication help them make their email
social media messages documents more
effective clear and mistake-free so
gramley has a very big mission improving
lives by improving communication it's so
big it almost sounds undoable not not
just not books travel and today I'm
going to tell you how it is actually
possible to do how this can be done and
we're doing it now millions of users are
using grammarly and it materially
improves their lives and I promise you
if you install grammerly after this
conference your life is going to get
better even if just tiny a little bit
it's going to get better
so this mission is real we live by it
but it's so big it may seem it's not
something that can be bootstrap but we
did it and today I'm going to share with
you framework that helped us do it and
just to illustrate what I mean by good
scale by kind of we did it this is not
to brag there's just some numbers to
show you what I mean by by the scale of
our company so it all started in 2004
when my co-founder and I decided that
it's time to get real it's time to build
a real company so we read a lot of
manuals mostly from Ikea and we
assembled our first office in Tirana
as you can see on this picture micro
powder Alex was the brain of the
operation and I was the muscle
so that's why he got the windows eat yes
that's how are you who's trekking looks
like it's not very glamorous I admit it
but it's just a start so in 2009 until
2009 we were focused on plagiarism
detection which is kind of a very niche
area but it's related to communication
and in 2009 our understanding of
communication evolved our vision evolved
and we we had new missions how people
communicate better and we realize it was
very ambitious it was very difficult
from a technology standpoint and it had
massive market it was diverse because
communication problems and needs are
different for everybody so what do we do
is it too much to bootstrap but we
decided to give it a try we had some
experience we had some learnings from
previous projects so we decided to give
it a try and what helps us get through
it will help us do this was a kind of a
three element framework that I'm going
to show will share with you today and I
very much hope it's going to help at
least some of you to do something big
and do something impactful so step
number one is may look familiar to some
of you I guess many here know the
concept of MVP if you don't google it
it's very useful concept it's great
concept but challenge with it is that
most people applied incorrectly they
just go straight to the product they
minimize their product they go with
minim and it's easy to make this mistake
because it says Minimum Viable Product
right so they go straight to the product
you have to start your MVP with your
market you have to pick a small
homogeneous segment with one pane that
sold by small fraction of functionality
that you're envisioning building
eventually and this functionality is
something that going to be useful to the
rest of your market at some point so let
me illustrate it with a diagram what it
actually means how how that works so
let's say on the
to access you have product functionality
frog death like how much value you're
creating for users and on a horizontal
one you have market breadth like the
size of your market so and in the area
of the chart is the amount of work you
have to do together the blue shaded area
is your ultimate vision it's like 10 15
20 years of work so you don't want to
start there you want to do something
smaller trim it and what most people end
up with is what I call typical MVP is
that gray area at the bottom here it's
broad because you're building for
everyone and it's very thin because all
you have limited resources so what you
end up with you're spending a ton of
work to build something that barely
qualifies as a toy and people forget
about it in like few weeks but if you
MVP your market first if you find this
very small group very homogeneous group
and build your MVP specifically for them
just for them you're going to end up
doing much much less work and the
product is going to be better so that it
not only gets kind of elevated to the
level of 2 rather than toy but you can
also charge money for it which is
extremely important for a bootstrap
product you get early revenue very
quickly and just using Bramley as an
example again our MVP market was
academics students researchers
instructors and that strong pain is we
identify for them was making documents
making papers compliant with rigorous
academic standards and that team could
be sold by a subset of checks of
corrections suggestions that would be
needed for other people as well so we
were not deviating from our long term
vision of just like building building a
two-level how people communicate and
just let me give you an example of what
this optimization of buildings that MVP
for that tiny small market gave us for
example pretty much everyone 99 percent
of our potential market wanted feedback
in real time you type any see feedback
you see suggestions but academics didn't
they were fine waiting five minutes 10
minutes and 15 minutes to get feedback
on their document why because they spent
weeks writing with it so extra five
minutes doesn't matter they just go get
a cup of coffee and that realization
optimizing for that allows us to not
worry about speed and worry about
accuracy more but it also allowed us to
cut engineering costs by 50 percent and
cut server server costs by more than
five times and that's just one
optimization so don't underestimate the
step try to go with a narrow market
first MVP or market first before and
gain your product now moving on to step
number two sell before you build and
it's easy to be easier to explain with
an example how we did it so as soon as
we had specifications for our MVP we
went to a bunch of conferences trade
shows for our target market academics
and try to sell the product just using
paired demos and it was invaluable it
got us feedback on the product it got us
validation of some of their our ideas
and the bonus point it also lined up
first buyers so that we had first
revenue literally days after release the
product literally days that's extremely
important for start-up again because
basically our first buyers funded the
rest of the company and this approach
applies not only to b2b not only to
sales if you are working on a consumer
product it still applies there's a way
to do it for example for our consumer
focused features we used AdWords to
advertise upcoming big features and see
how people respond to them if people
click on ads in what numbers to help us
prioritize those features so essentially
we kind of pre sold tested the features
before they were developed with with
real users here is an example of open
you of kind of a mailing we did to
potential educational customers and this
example reminds me of one very important
point I want to make when you do pre
selling or kind of selling something is
you don't have like smoke testing
very easy to kind of a not be completely
ethical please don't do that
it's possible to do that in a completely
ethical way without any bait-and-switch
or anything like that be ethical and
just if you put your mind to it you can
completely do it in a very positive and
ethical way an example one of the kind
of tricks we use to make sure that it's
completely fine when we sold somebody on
the feature that we didn't have we
actually gave them a free trial that
ended after we released that feature so
before they actually paid us money they
saw the complete product that was
promised to them and as a result of our
approach to this as of this approach to
this reselling every customer we sold
product that we didn't have eventually
was completely happy and we use them as
references to build more and more
customers so be ethical if it's worth it
it pays off expand project the market
innovations that's the final step and
that's where most people fail that's
where big dreams die so pay attention
they kind of the trick here the main
principle here is build for your next
segment not for the segment's not as
much for the segments you have now and
just use an example to illustrate it not
quite an example with analogy what is
more valuable building for 10,000 users
that you have or for 1 million users
that you're about to have of course the
latter so think about it this way it's
very helpful but of course it's never
black and white whatever you build helps
both your existing users and your new
users so how do you balance that I use
this formula where you basically take
size of your current segment and benefit
to it and size of the new segment and
benefit to it and factor in the risk and
it kind of spits out the the relative
value of anything new you build and it's
very helpful for evaluating new
opportunities and things you can build
so this is how this looks when you put
it back on the on the grass which we saw
earlier you expand your market you
and your product functionality for that
market and gradually you delight more
and more users so some do's and don'ts
kind of a to sum it up and to make this
model even more practical and useful
first don't bite off too much small
quick steps are less risky they are
[Music]
generating revenue quicker you're going
to be going to releasing new features
expanding your market in smaller but
quicker steps and each each new
improvement is going to help you get
more revenue which is a very important
for bootstrap company then don't get
stuck chasing your tail this is a big
mistake that many people make and let me
explain what I mean by this let's say
you had success on a specific segment of
the market and as a result of that all
the feedback that you got all the data
that you're collecting is going to be
about that segment but it's not going to
teach you about users you don't have
users that you have are very poor at
teaching you about users that you don't
have so you have to realize that you
have to break out of it you have to go
out of your existing user base go out of
the data that's easily available to you
and look broader look to your next
segment look to you to - expansion and
keep focused on your vision and then
finally expect each next steps to be
harder initially if you've done good job
creating your MVP kind of stacking out
your MVP you collected although hanging
fruit you skimmed all the cream you
killed flocks of birds with one stone
you've done all that but once you've
done all that it's over it's no longer
that easy
so each next step is going to be
progressively get more difficult and
again it seems obvious but most people
don't think that I like that they fall
into the trap of thinking well I'm
getting better at what I do I'm getting
more resources my company is growing
bigger so each day except should be
easier no it's the other way around if
you've done your job right you've done
all the easy things in the beginning and
each next thing is going to be more more
and more difficult and yes that says
it's a very simple framework I really
hope it's going to help how
some of you guys build something new
doesn't even have to be a start-up it
may be a product within your existing
company it can be applied pretty broadly
and it worked really well for Emily we
started as I mentioned we started as a
very narrow to four very narrow market
on purpose and then right now we have a
breadth
we have broad suite of a high-powered
products that how people improve
different aspects of their communication
from effectiveness tone correctness
clarity pretty much all across the board
and that's just the beginning
Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]